do you think there's ever gonna be a
time in in humans like whether it's a
hundred years from now or thousand years
now where there's no war yes yes I do
how do you see that happening well it's
gonna start with cop cars with flags on
them and they're gonna patrol our hands
I think it would be technology and I
think it's a matter of everybody
becoming more comfortable if you can if
you can have people this is like a
Thomas Friedman idea that if if you want
to stop like people fighting in the
Middle East give them all the comforts
of a good Society let them be able to go
eat McDonald's and sit in a coffee shop
and all of a sudden you don't want to
fight as much that means prosperity that
means popping so I think technology if
you bring more water to people and
there's less suffering if climate change
doesn't Jam ruin all of that I think if
you can prop these people up and give
all these people if they can rise and
there's no sense I mean we're at a point
now where there's fewer Wars than ever
before on the planet sure so we're
headed in that direction so I don't see
why not well as a thought exercise let's
look at it this way
what makes anybody decide to act as a
group what makes anybody like if why
would we decide to go if right what
negotiations should we be having with
someone in Germany like why why why are
we having a conversation about anything
you live way the fuck over there on the
other side of the ocean what would make
people act as a group and go over and
try to fuck with somebody else that's
right that's in another place like well
people can be people can definitely be
rallied alright for any cause most
certainly but do you think this is my
thought that there will come a time
where that kind of rallying doesn't work
mm-hmm that people will stop believing I
mean this is one of those very bizarre
ideas that the systems that we've
established for for human civilizations
well yes countries or cities or
continents right whatever it is yeah
these systems
once all the boundaries that kept people
from freely traveling although once
those are broken down no country anymore
they keeping it this keeping it together
now is the fact that it's air travel so
they know when you're coming in they get
to check your papers right oh you're
flying in from overseas are you mr. papa
well there's only one way motherfucker
you got to land right here right in this
spot and then we take each individual
and say can I see your paperwork what do
you got who are you where are you from
where are you born do you have money or
you're drug addict you've been arrested
and then they're allowed they could
still do that that way that didn't exist
if it was way easier to go to Germany
yeah there was a technology that would
allow you like a person like you or me
the same way we could drive places we
could just fly into somewhere and land
anywhere yeah you'd have to go to a
fucking specific location like an
airport huh or get funneled through a
road that takes you to some you know
right some checkpoint station like when
you're trying to drive open borders just
if people could fly
yeah if people if people flew anywhere
they wanted to go if that technology
existed good fucking luck keeping people
from coming into your city good luck all
those rules are out the window
yeah all those immigration rules that
doesn't exist anymore
right and exist people can go anywhere
they want to refit but what are you
saying that gives you well it gives you
the interaction with human beings like
you you won't be able to get them as a
group as easily to go after another
group right because now there's no
country basically there's no like thing
- right we're not part of this that has
to go fight that right we're all one now
here's the - of one person lives in a
great spot they don't want to give up
their oil right right then it becomes a
problem right come on resources we're
all in this together those people in
Alaska you know yeah they got all that
fucking oil bro here's here's two things
though here's two things of why it might
not work once this ecology
thousand-point yeah but only to that I
can think of one
Italians or Italians and Germans or
Germans and Mexicans or Mexicans and you
get around your people and you feel it
and you know it and I know who you are
and we're part of that tribe and we're
part
that thing and it doesn't matter that we
grew up somewhere I just know you as an
Italian and I'm an Italian and I am with
you and that is very different from that
Turkish guy over there hmm
that thing that very human thing
chemistry thing of your own blood your
own thing I don't think that's gonna go
away for it bro you're old school and
you bake bread you're talking nonsense
anything I do level thank you fix your
eyes without glasses but now I like the
classic I put them on get ready to go to
work okay but I think that's a real
thing better than cars and your friend
and a your friend you give him hey stop
that bad and the shit is actually really
good for fertilizer